I started as an art student who designed
sets and costumes for stage performances
just because I enjoyed it nobody else
wanted to do it it seemed and pretty
quickly I realized they really loved
doing that so I went to grad school
studying that and got a degree and moved
to New York with the intention of
working on theater in New York for this
in my life and I did about three years
in Tony Walton stereo and his Broadway
shows and when that lost its charm I
discovered there were in ways into
television and feature work there in New
York City so I became an assistant art
director on some features and pretty
quickly realized that I wanted to become
the big boss I worked long enough with
some really talented heavyweight
production designers patrizia von
brandenstein when Thomas did a show with
him Stewart wurtzel as an assistant art
director and after one of those projects
I was recommended to the friend of a
friend who was doing a low-budget
feature to design it for him and I like
the material and I like the director so
I got my first feature pretty quickly
one of those one point out
million-dollar features back then most
people don't know what the production
designer is they I'm most frequently
referred to as a set designer or an hour
director just because even within our
own Union and within our own ranks what
we do is variously called our direction
or production design depending on who's
speaking really so I think there's
there's simply a an unclear label to
begin with I describe myself as the
visual storyteller who works with the
director and the writers and
occasionally the producers to to come up
with the concept of what the setting of
the story is and my two right hands I
don't have a left hand but super visor
our director and a set decorator who
work with me a very close collaboration
in coming up with with what the vision
is and how to
bring it to to fruition
you